uh cool all right thanks uh
thanks everybody and uh and welcome
and yeah so today uh i wanna talk to you
about
javascript um my
wife made me at the slide i was just
gonna jump in but um david introduced me
um so i don't need to say too much here
but yeah i was the cto
of a company called tamagi from uh
2006 to 2017. i remain the
uh top contributor to our main
repository which is a source of pride
for me i'm sure i'll get past soon
um and since 2017 i uh
sort of have become kind of a serial
side project
maker um an entrepreneur so i kind of
make internet experiments and uh try to
try to sell things online um
yeah so javascripts uh why are we
talking about
javascript at pike um and so your first
reaction is probably javascript
and then your second reaction might be
something like this
which i won't read aloud um
but but yeah javascript kind of maybe
gets a little bit of a bad
rap in uh in the programming world this
is
uh another one that you kind of see
tossed around
um the joke being that there aren't very
many good parts
of javascript and when i was just sort
of googling for memes i found this one
which
uh yeah i don't really understand it but
i love how happy the python guy looks um
so i thought i would throw it in here
um but yeah so i think i think
javascript
you know can be stigmatized especially
by those in the python world who think
that python is sort of the greatest
thing in the world which which
you know i actually you know i kind of
believe and probably a lot of us do
um but if if you're a web developer uh
in
in 2020 then you probably
need to use javascript um it's
everywhere
it's sort of unavoidable at this point
um and also i will say
that you know javascript it's not so bad
um it's it's come a long way in the last
uh
in the last 10 or 15 years since since i
first started my
um my career in web development and and
i'll i'll show you a few of the
a few of the things that you may or may
not know that javascript does these days
and can do these days
but yeah once you once you wrap your
head around it the modern
javascript ecosystem is
is uh and developer experience is
actually is actually pretty
pretty decent um yeah so
in uh 2008 when i first sort of started
doing a lot of web development
javascript was pretty straightforward it
was sort of this thing that you put on
your website when you wanted to
add some dynamic functionality maybe
like a little modal
uh or an auto completion widget or
something like that
and you threw it on maybe maybe use
jquery
that was kind of around back then but by
and large it was sort of this
this relatively simple um and for
anybody who's tried to sort of
get into javascript in 2020 it looks a
lot more like this
uh you may or may not recognize some of
these logos all of these logos
but essentially javascript today is
there's a ton going on there's there's
package managers there's frameworks
there
there are entirely new versions of the
language like typescript
and and it's quite a lot it's quite
intimidating
and especially as sort of someone who
identifies as a python developer
just kind of wanting to use javascript
to to serve my
sort of web development needs it was
it was really difficult to uh to sort of
break into this world and figure out
what all was going on here um and so my
goal
is is to teach you i guess sort of what
i've learned
um hopefully what you need to know uh in
order to use modern javascript
in in your web apps in 2020 um and
i'm assuming you uh like me are python
developers my background is primarily in
django i've built a few flask apps so a
lot of the examples in this talk
uh will be based on django um and i'll
say that
at the top that this this talk is based
on a series of articles that i wrote
um and i'll link to those uh in the in
the discourse
and um and in the slides um so there's a
lot more detail in there
so hopefully if i if i go too fast or i
cover things
uh that you don't uh but don't land um
there's you can always go back and and
refer to these articles where there's
sort of
a lot more detail a lot more depth to
everything i'm gonna talk about
so i want to kind of start by uh
by sort of describing how most front-end
code bases that i've worked on have
evolved
um and so you know we would start out
where
you know for me it's usually django um
but you know building out a site using
your normal sort of django or flask
tools your your views and your templates
um you realize you need something
dynamic to happen on the page
and so you go to stack overflow you find
a little snippet of javascript that
does the thing that you need you maybe
add a script tag
to include some library from a cdn uh or
maybe you maybe you copy and paste it
into your
app um and then you go to one
and this uh you know this this isn't
necessarily a bad thing and for
for small projects uh this works totally
fine
um if if your project is not sort of too
front end heavy
uh or too large um this isn't too much
of a problem you can go pretty far
but as your project gets bigger this can
create a lot of problems
here's here's an example from um one of
our repositories at zamagi
um and this is this is our base template
in django so this is sort of the the
template that
a lot of our other django views our
other django templates sort of inherit
from
and you can see here um i don't know if
you can see where my mouse is but
we um we have this pattern where we
annotate the request object in python
to say which libraries we're using so we
say like are we using nbd3
uh which is a graphing library on this
page and if so
then include these four um dependencies
that mdd3
use needs or are we using data tables
which
is a library that sort of does sorting
and search for data tables okay well
then we need these three libraries are
we using type ahead
um and so you know there are a couple
immediate problems with
with something like this this uh you
know first of all you're loading a lot
of scripts
on your page which is bad your
dependencies are also sort of
very far away from each other like this
this logic lives in some base template
um the thing that sets the the use
ndd property on the request is probably
in some python
view code somewhere and then the logic
that's actually
using nvd3 is probably in a different
javascript
place altogether and so this is quite
a common thing to happen to mature uh or
more mature
python apps as as they sort of take this
ad hoc approach to
um to sort of javascript and javascript
dependencies as they end up with
with a lot of this stuff sort of
scattered around in different places
uh it's pretty hard to reason with um
and so i call this pattern server first
um and it
you know it's kind of you start with the
with the web framework with the sort of
the django world or the flask world um
it's the most common one that that
python developers choose and i put shoes
in quotes because you kind of you don't
really choose this architecture you sort
of
stumble into it over over the course of
months or years of
of slowly adding front-end stuff to your
app um
and in this world as you saw usually the
javascript is included ad hoc
at the page lump level sometimes that's
that's baked into your template
hierarchy sometimes it's not
um and yeah like i said it sort of gets
more and more
unwieldy over time um and another thing
which we'll see
later is you're not really taking
advantage of of what javascript can do
today
um so i kind of lovingly gave this the
mascot of of the spaghetti monster
because
you know not not that your whole code is
spaghetti but your front end code base
kind of gets spread around uh all all
different places
and so it becomes a little bit
spaghetti-like
so right so is there a better way to do
this and if you
if you sort of start from uh you know
2020 i want to build my most modern my
best
uh web application that i can
um you'll probably end up finding
something that recommends you do
something like this
and so in this world you basically you
create two separate
entirely separate projects you have uh
you have your sort of frontend project
uh and and that might be its own
entirely
distinct code base and then you have
your back end project
and the only way they know about each
other and the only way they talk to each
other is through apis
so these are often run by different
processes one might be running in node
and one might be running in python they
might be running on two
different uh subdomains and
um and this is nice like uh
this this has a lot of upside it it
plainly separates your your back end and
your front end
and that can be really good if
especially if you have
a team and you have a team of javascript
people and a team of python people
and and nobody wants to sort of cross
the chasm uh then you get this really
nice
uh separation um some of the downsides
of this towards the bottom like your
your back end
basically becomes an api factory and so
like in the django world
you know you're throwing away django
views by and large you're throwing away
all of the templating system
um similarly in the flask you're in the
flask world you're not really using
jinja flask is just
it's just serving apis um and for us as
python developers you
like when you're doing development on
the front end you you lose that sort of
like familiarity of
you know oh this is how i've been making
websites for the last 10 years and now
you're asking me to like do this
entirely new
totally different thing and i'm only
allowed to write apis um
and so the result of that makes um
simple stuff more difficult it kind of
it makes your deployment architecture a
bit more complicated and so
this isn't always ideal either and
certainly
for me as as like a single person doing
doing my own
sort of like full stack projects this um
i didn't want to sort of like take on
all these weights when when i thought
you know why why can't we just use
these two things together um so this one
yeah i
i didn't have as good a mascot for this
one so i i call it the energizer buddy
and the analogy is that
um you're bringing your own batteries
like
you're throwing out the batteries that
are provided by the python framework and
you sort of have to bring all your own
stuff to the table you have to
re-implement everything
um in in this sort of like new api
pattern
um so this i'm not going to read through
all of this
um but this this is taken from the guide
and sort of talks about
the differences between these two um and
yeah i mean basically one is kind of
usually started by server developers
one's usually started by
uh javascript developers they have sort
of different
properties around whether they use
frameworks how they manage the
javascript
tooling and all that um and they both
have pros and cons but but i have found
that
that neither has been sort of ideal for
me
um and so the architecture that i that i
like
and the one that i use for for most apps
these days and and that i recommend
the most is is what i call a hybrid
application
and in a hybrid application you you
basically mix and match these two things
and so rather than saying you know
uh my front end and my back end need to
be completely decoupled
or um not taking any sort of uh
structured approach to to organizing
your front end code you sort of mix and
match these two things at the page level
um and what this allows you to do is
take the power of modern javascript and
and there is good stuff in there um
combine it with the familiarity that
you're used to with with your python web
frameworks
and um and develop applications that's
uh sort of sort of meet both sides um
a big downside of this is that you kind
of have to
dip your toes into javascript build
tooling and that
is not always the most fun uh
process and so yeah so i wanna
tell just like a short story of of my
own experience
um adding react to to a django project
and so this would have been sort of like
right when i step down to maggie i'm
like building my first side project
i hear that this thing react is like all
the cool kids are using it i should be
using it
and so i'm like okay i'm gonna like use
react in this project it's gonna be it's
gonna be great
and so i go to the react uh
you know the tutorial and they have this
sort of hello world
code and you know for those of you who
who
know modern javascript like this this
doesn't look too crazy
for those of you who don't and for me at
the time what what am i
looking at like what is what is that
import like how how does that import
work and where does that
lie like can i even do that and
and then you go down and you see this
this you know this h1 but it's
you think it should be a string but it's
it's not escaped by strings and you're
like what what am i looking at
and if you if you put this code into a
browser
into a javascript file and you try to
run it like it's not going to work like
this isn't
valid javascript code and yet it's sort
of front and center
in the react hello world and like my
head is like kind of exploding
um but what i figured out pretty quickly
is oh i
i need a tool chain um and so
yeah so why why tool chains and and the
short answer is
is so that we can do uh new good stuff
with javascript and uh also support
legacy browsers and you know like i
imagine
a lot of us have gone through you know
the python two to three migration
and um and we all know how painful that
can be
um in the javascript world you don't
really have that option
like your your code needs to run on
you know it needs to run on ideally you
know
seven or eight different browsers you
know all these mobile phones
and and you have very little control of
of what particular version of javascript
is going to run
on uh any particular device that your
code is running on and so you have to be
very defensive about it and so
the way that the javascript community
has
has gotten around that is they have
introduced
tool chains that essentially allow you
to write newer better
uh easier to reason with javascript code
um and then they turn that code into
something that browsers can actually
deal with
um so that's what the tool chain does
that's that's why you need it it's so
that you can do stuff like this
and um and not have it crash
on browsers when you open them
so okay so i need a tool chain what tool
change should i use and and so the react
documentation has some advice on this
and uh you know my first reaction was
kind of like okay this looks like a lot
of options
um but okay i'm integrating with an
existing code base
so i'll go check out this more flexible
tool chain section
um and so i go over there and i'm i'm
reading this and i'm thinking like okay
neutrino combines the power of webpack
with the simplicity of priests
nyx is a tool kit for full stack and
like
i don't know what like it
maybe this makes sense to to you all or
to somebody but
when i read this i'm just like what is
like what is all this stuff and what
like what are even these words and like
why do they all sound so funny
and um and yeah it's it's funny like
my first experience like getting into
this this
sort of like javascript world that i had
never been a part of was like it was
very
humbling and sort of like it caused me
to like have some kind of like
you know am i like not like i thought i
was like a professional web developer i
thought i sort of like understood what
was going on and
i'm reading all these words that that
barely makes sense to me
um but it's it's not this complicated
and you don't
really need to care about all these
different options if your only goal is
is to use modern javascripts um i'm sure
the javascript people have
have very strong opinions about about
these various tools but but
you don't need to if you're just sort of
trying to get something done
um and so yeah so these are the basic
elements of the tool chain and
and most of the tool chains will look
something like this
with with possible replacements of these
different uh
specific tools but essentially you have
a compiler
uh you have a bundler and you have a
package manager
and i'll quickly talk about each of
those individually
um so the package manager is the easiest
one and
and the one line answer is it's it's pit
for javascript
um so this is the thing that will where
you'll put your request
in uh into a file it
you know you'll give it versions it it
manages your dependencies for you it
does your installations for you
um so it's it's it's almost one to one
with pip
npm does you know they both do other
stuff um but you don't really need to
worry about that
um in in the javascript world there's
two main packages made package managers
and uh people will argue about which
ones to use
um but npm is sort of the most popular
one uh
and it's the one that i recommend um and
i'll say like
when i recommend these tools it's not
from the perspective of like i know
everything about javascript and these
are definitely the tools you should use
but these are the most
popular ones and you you can't really
go wrong if you use them if you do want
to sort of
get really into this stuff you can you
can go read you know 100 articles about
npm and yarn and decide
which one you want to use but um but
that wasn't something that i
i felt the need to do
so that's the package manager um the
next thing is the compiler and the
compiler is the thing that lets you
write
uh that code like the um
h1 thing that we saw in the react
example um so it'll it'll take sort of
new stuff that's been added both to
javascript and
um extensions that that you know other
people have come up with like typescript
or jsx which which i'll talk about in a
little bit
um and turn them into browser
browser-friendly javascript
so that's the thing that's that's doing
the work of uh
translating the modern stuff into into
the stuff that your browsers can
can deal with um and babel or babel
i'm not sure how to pronounce it um is
the most popular compiler
out there um and it's the one i sort of
recommend using
and then the last thing is the bundler
and
and the bundler does it kind of does two
things um
one thing it does is it bundles uh your
code so
it's pretty well named um and and the
thing that it does is it manages
dependencies for you
and that's part of the bundling process
um so if you remember this example i
showed where we had this sort of
you know all these different libraries
were being included based on this
property that was was manually set um
if you just use those those import
statements in your javascript code
then your bundler will will figure out
that you need those libraries it'll get
them for you
it'll get the dependencies of those
libraries but it won't it won't grab
everything that's installed and it it'll
sort of
figure out what it needs and then create
a single bundle file
and so the other thing it does is you
know you see on this page there's you
know
20 some odd different files that might
get included and this isn't even
sort of a complete example but it'll
it'll take all that stuff and just put
it into one file
and so if you have it all in one file
that's uh fewer
requests that your page has to make
which will make your site more
performance
um and again there's there's a lot of
bundlers out there
but webpack is sort of the gold standard
and the most popular one
so yeah so that was a lot of
information quickly um but to put it all
together
npm is is going to be our pip it's going
to deal with
all the libraries that we want to use um
babel will take our modern javascript
and turn it into browser friendly bundle
uh javascript and webpack will
sort of take all those things bundle
them together create
this one nice javascript file
and we can finally have a hello world
so yeah so that's that's a lot of effort
um but but it is it is worth it and it's
it's a one-time sort of exercise that
you have to go through
um and and in the in the guides i have
sort of very
detailed instructions on on how you can
do all this stuff uh set it up in
in a django project um
in terms of putting it into into a
project
um this this is a django example and so
you sort of you you have that whole
pipeline there uh on the left-hand side
and then you just all you really need is
that bundle file
right so the then you just treat the
bundle file as
uh as any other static file as you would
an image or a css file um and then you
do your normal thing with
with views and templates and um
and then you can use you can use any of
this modern javascript directly
in in a django app or in a flask app um
by only just sort of
referencing this file and and having
having this thing in place on the left
to
to create it um
yeah so in practice uh this is one way
you could
you could structure that um and so you'd
have your sort of
your modern javascript source files in
in a project
folder uh i called it assets you can you
can call it whatever you want
and then you have some build tooling
that takes those and outputs them
into your normal um static files
directory
and then and then everything works sort
of the same way
and this assets folder it's never
referenced or used by django but it's
it's used to build your front-end source
um and and you could keep it outside of
the project but but i find that having
it inside the project is nice because
then you can sort of
do everything at once and really they
are sort of dependent on each other
um and yeah so this this is what
you know a single page react app then
becomes in this sort of
hybrid architecture that i mentioned so
you have your
uh your modern react thing over here it
goes through your pipeline
and then it gets included in your django
template just as a bundle like this
and you can see this like div id root is
in your template
and then the react thing knows to go
render itself
in your root template um so
yeah hopefully that makes sense i i
realize i
i sort of went very quickly through that
um
but there is uh a much more
comprehensive example of this
uh in the guide which but that's that's
the basic
things of it and then the rest is sort
of you know
how do you deal with auth and how do you
deal with apis and and all that
good stuff
right so so why bother with all of this
right so like
at the beginning i kind of said it would
be worth it um
and uh and it is like you you do end up
in
in a much better world in terms of in
terms of your front-end
code base um and so
what's the payoff like some some things
so
like you can you can use the latest
javascript frameworks um and and they
are they're
quite nice like um you know it's one of
those things where it's it's a
it can be you know a steeper learning
curve to start
working with them but once you wrap your
head around them and once you get
comfortable in them it
they really do uh increase your velocity
um they the experience of of building
uis and in some of these frameworks is
um is quite a bit nicer than than sort
of your standard
you know document.h you know
dot add event listener um or or the
jquery version of that
um you get the dependency management so
um you know you don't you don't have to
do any of that stuff yourself
all of your javascript dependencies can
be can be managed in
in sort of this import export fashion
that
that i showed in in the react example um
you get new features and convenient
syntaxes which i'll i'll show
uh a few um and you get uh
you know there's there's a ton of sort
of customization that that is not
in just javascript but people who have
their own opinions about how to make
javascript better
um and you can leverage any of that
stuff depending on what you want to use
um so yeah so hopefully it it kind of
gets rid of
gets rid of your front end speedy so
yeah one of one of the big things you
get is is es6 which is just like the
sixth
version of ecma script or something like
that but anyway it's it's it's like
later versions of javascript and it's
hilarious like basically they just like
added a bunch of features to make
javascript more like python
um but they are useful uh so one thing
they added
is arrow functions which are basically
lambdas
um and while this looks you know kind of
trivial in the same way that lambdas
look kind of trivial like you just
change the syntax of this
function thing um when you write a lot
of single line functions
then um these become really useful and
and i'll show you on the next slide
you know why why you end up writing a
lot more single line functions
um classes you know that's uh that's a
novel concept
um but but yeah so you know es6 adds
classes to javascript
um the constructor is basically your
init dot uh
or not your init function
function and um yeah
and and these work sort of how you would
expect
um they have something called template
strings which are basically f strings
um so the syntax is similar to f strings
except they add a little
dollar sign here um but you can
essentially
put uh you can escape this
you know name variable in brackets and
it'll
render appropriately and and like f
strings you can you can put sort of like
arbitrary uh uh javascript code in here
um like one line javascript code so uh
you can do
a lot of much more powerful string
formatting than sort of the
the traditional like string plus string
clustering
thing that um that we've been doing for
so long
um and default argument values so also
just sort of like something that's been
in python forever
um but yeah so you can have uh optional
arguments uh and instead of being
undefined which they would be in
javascript
uh they will get assigned whatever the
default value
is um and there's a bunch more stuff
as well these were just some of the
highlights that i pulled out
um another thing so this this is kind of
a react
thing um but is so so this this is that
h1 thing that i showed you
uh a while back but essentially it's
it's a language called jsx and
it's kind of like string templating for
html
um and it's it's funny at first and it
takes some getting used to
um but it it is really nice in that it
it provides a really
easy way to sort of write code that
looks like html but add
business logic inside of it that can do
complicated
functions and so this would obviously
render
you know hello uh what is its harper
perez on your page and
um this is one place where uh
where those arrow functions are useful
if if you want to do
complicated bindings and other stuff in
in these templates
then um you end up using a lot of sort
of one-line functions
um vue uh which is another popular
javascript framework has a different
take on this sort of
a lot of these frameworks what they're
trying to do is they're trying to make
it easier
to combine html uh with
uh your styles and with your business
logic
and so vue defines this format where
the view file is broken into three parts
there's a template which is
kind of the html um there's the script
area which defines the
uh the business logic in here of of you
know
what's actually gonna gonna happen with
your data and then there's
styles that get applied um and and one
nice thing about
this view example is these styles can be
scoped which means
that this um the style will only get
applied to the
ps in this file um so it's a nice way to
to um to avoid having
clobbering your global styles uh for for
a particular component
so again this this is it becomes a nice
way to
uh to build uis in in sort of a way that
the whole ui is contained together
rather than sort of being out in
a bunch of different places um
and yeah and that's honestly that's
that's really the tip of the iceberg
i feel like i know maybe you know this
this top part of the iceberg as well
um but there's there's a ton
going on in the javascript world these
days um
modern javascript is actually not so bad
um and i encourage you to use it and
and bring it into your python projects
uh yeah thanks and so yeah like i said
if
if you want to see sort of code samples
and anything else
uh you can go to sas saskpegasus.com
which is
um one of my side projects and then just
click guides and
um you'll find like a super long
write-up on
all of this stuff and if you want to
find me i'm csu
pretty much everywhere but especially
twitter and and z-a-tech
slack